hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about the real purpose of cholesterol
the heart killer right well not really
let's talk about exactly what this
cholesterol is there's so much confusion
people are freaked out about it because
they're worried that it's going to clog
your arteries so they get their blood
test and it's it's high they freak out
let's just take a look at some facts
related to cholesterol almost all of the
cholesterol in your body actually
doesn't come from your diet it's not
coming from your diet almost every cell
in your body will make cholesterol so
the majority of cholesterol that you
have in your body is coming from your
own body your body makes 3,000
milligrams of cholesterol every single
day your liver makes a thousand the rest
of the cells make 200 mm okay now that
would be equivalent to a pound of butter
or 14 eggs or 300 strips of bacon that's
a lot of cholesterol right your
cholesterol is on a negative feedback
loop so if you eat more your body makes
less if you eat less your body makes
more so here's the question you need to
be asking why why does your body make so
much
if cholesterol is so bad and by the way
LDL HDL the good and bad cholesterol
that's not really cholesterol LDL is low
density lipoproteins as a protein it's a
shuttle that carries cholesterol through
the body HDL is high density lipoprotein
that's a shuttle a protein shuttle that
carries cholesterol from the body so HDL
is the cholesterol coming from the
arteries back to the liver and LDL is
the cholesterol coming from your liver
to the body okay and they consider that
it's not bad I'll put a link down below
talking about LDL a lot more but I just
want to give you some facts about the
purpose of cholesterol so why do we need
it why is it so important because your
cell membranes 50% of the cell membranes
and every single cell you have it's like
a trillion cells 50% of those cells are
made from cholesterol okay
the structure of the cells especially
your brain and the nervous system and
the myelin sheath around the nervous
so what are cell membranes the cell
membrane is permeable it allows
nutrition electrolytes molecules to go
in and out of the cell it protects the
cell against microbes and foreign
viruses and things like that so it
allows electrolytes to travel it
protects the central nervous system
which is the brain in the spinal column
it it actually is involved in making
bile bi le that's the detergent helps
you break down the fat to actually
assimilate the essential fatty acids and
the fat soluble vitamins so you need
cholesterol to make vitamin D to
actually help make the bile that helps
you absorb vitamin A and E and even k2
so these are all essential fat soluble
vitamins that you need that without
cholesterol you can make the bile to
extract them from the food that you eat
cholesterol is needed as a raw material
precursor for adrenal hormones so the
more stress that you go through the more
cholesterol that you're going to make
because the body needs those hormones to
adapt to stress sex hormones estrogen
testosterone is made from cholesterol
this is one of the reasons why statin
drugs one of the side effects is men
they lose their libido women have
problems with estrogen and progesterone
and even androgen so there's a lot of
issues with that your cholesterol is
there to make myelin so there's even
another video that I just released has
to do with MS in the relationship to
dysfunctional myelin which is the lipid
layer around the nervous system in the
brain and if you're actually on a low
cholesterol diet you can worsen that
condition so the cholesterol also is
there to feed the immune system your
immune system needs cholesterol to
function
partly because cortisol from the adrenal
is necessary for the immune system
controls the white blood cell and then
also cholesterol is
to fight infection and to combat the
toxic effects from bacteria one of the
purposes of LVL the so called bad
cholesterol is to and I created a whole
separate video on this is to neutralize
the toxins from bacteria in the cell
it's always considered the the bad guy
but it's really yes it's at the scene of
the crime but it's really there to
actually heal whatever is there like a
lesion or some type of ulcer and so
people mistakenly assume that for that
guy when really it's a good guy trying
to heal and you should just say wipe if
your body makes it why would be
considered a bad thing people never ask
those questions so changes of season
during the winter months the cholesterol
goes up because it's you're actually
trying to make some of these hormones to
adapt to the the change of season also
during stress and surgery your cluster
goes up to make more cortisol but I just
wanted to put this video together to
show you that that's the real purpose of
cholesterol it has a purpose and anytime
it's high you have to ask why why is it
high rather than just automatically
bring it down with some drug okay thanks
for watching
hey you probably already subscribed but
if you haven't press this little button
down below and I will keep you updated